[موسيقى]
اسعد الله مساءكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض والتي نقدم من
خلالها ابرز اخبار ملفات السعوديه والخليج
وهذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
الجيش الاسرائيلي يستدعي عشرات ضباط
الاحتياط ووزير الدفاع يوجه بزياده تامين
المستوطنات
رويتر تعلن عن امكانيه اعلان هدنه بين
اليمنيين قبل العيد اذا نجحت محادثات
تقودها الرياض ومسقط
الصندوق السعودي للتنميه يوقع اتفاقيه
لتمويل بناء سد في باكستان بنحو ربع مليار
دولار
في الرابعه ايضا
ارتفاع عدد ركاب المطارات السعوديه باكثر
من 80% خلال عام 2022
ايات النقل السعوديه تدشن اول حافله
كهربائيه للنقل الترددي بين مطار المدينه
والحرم النبوي
حياكم الله فهد مراسل العربيه بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي استدعى العشرات من ضباط
الاحتياط من القوات الخاصه واعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي استدعاء جنود الاحتياط مع
التركيز على الدفاع الجوي وسلاح الجو
جانبه قال وزير خارجيه اسرائيل ان الارهاب
يرفع راسه داعيا الى الرد بحرب حازمه وضرب
الاعداء على حد قوله
افاد مراسل العربيه بارتفاع قتل عمليه
اطلاق النار في الاغوار الى ثلاث مستوطنات
واشارت التحقيقات الاوليه الى ان اطلاق
النار نفذه شخصان واكدت وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه ان الجيش مازال يطارد المنفدين
واغلق طرق رئيسيه ومنافذ كل من اريحا
ونابلس لمنعه هروب المنفذ كما دفع الجيش
بتعزيزات اضافيه في الاغوار فيما يجري
رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو مشاورات
امنيه مع كبار المسؤولين لتقييم الوضع
الامني بعد اطلاق النار
وتاتي هذه العمليه تزامنا مع التصعيد
الاسرائيلي في القدس وغزه وجنوب لبنان
الذي استمرت طوال الليل ليعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي صباحا عوده الحياه الى طبيعتها
في المنطقه الحدوديه مع قطاع غزه ولبنان
واكد متحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي انه لا
ضروره لبقاء سكان منطقه غلاف غزه بالقرب
من الملاج ياتي بعد ذلك بعد قصف الجيش
الاسرائيلي مواقع في لبنان وغزه ردا على
اطلاق صواريخ استهدفت مناطق في اسرائيل
ومعنا من الحدود الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه
مدير مكتب العربيه زياد حلبي ومن جنوب
لبنان محمود شكر مراسل العربيه اهلا بكم
معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض ابدا معك
زياد الجيش الاسرائيلي استدع العشرات من
الضباط ضباط الاحتياط من القوات الخاصه
ركز ايضا على الدفاع الجوي وعلى ايضا كذلك
سلاح الجو لماذا تاتي هذه الخطوه الان هل
تستبق شيئا ما
قد يكون ذلك وقد يكون لانها عمليا
الوضع الامني الان بات مركبا جدا في ظل ما
نراه عمليا من يعني المعادله توحيد
الساحات والانفجار في اكثر من جبهه
وبالتالي اساسا مثلا على حدود لبنان وعلى
حدود قطاع غزه كانت هناك حاجه على ما يبدو
بقوات احتياط طابعه للدفاعات الجويه بسبب
الضغط الذي حصل على هذه القوات في الفتره
الاخيره قد يدلل او قد لا يدلل بالضروره
على المستقبل بمعنى كانت اسرائيل تخطط
لشيء ما لا ولكن هذا في اطار اتحاد امور
اجراءات
استباقيه لامور من هذا النوع السبب
وفي جزء على الاقل ايضا ربما كي يقول رئيس
الاركان الاسرائيليين ووزير الدفاع بان
هناك اجراءات تتخذ في ظل عمليا نوع من
العجز الامني في بعض الامور مثل قضيه
العمليات الفرديه التي كانت ربما اسوا ما
حدث بالنسبه لاسرائيل في اليومين الاخيرين
عمليا مقتل المستوطنات الاسرائيليات طيب
اليك ايضا محمود الاوضاع في جنوب لبنان
كيف تبدو بعد القصف الاسرائيلي الذي طالها
ليله البارحه وربما حتى ايضا الى اللحظات
الاولى من فجر اليوم كيف يمكن تقييم الوضع
حتى هذه اللحظه
وبالفعل هذا الذي اردناه من هذا المباشر
حيث انتقل من الاماكن التي استهدفها
الطيران بالغارات الفجر الى منطقه الصور
وتحديدا بالقرب من مخيم الراشديه كما
تشاهد معي الحركه هي الطبيعيه في الشوارع
الرئيسيه في المدينه حركه السير المؤسسات
التجاريه المر على جوانب الطرقات وخاصه
الى اننا نتحدث الى انه في لبنان اليوم هي
عطله الرسميه بالاضافه ايضا الى التحضير
هذه الحركه تكون قبل موعد الافطار وعليه
الى ان هذه الغارات التي حصلت مع ساعات
الفجر كان الارتباك لحوالي تقريبا ساعه من
الوقت شاهدنا مع تحديدا على هذه الطرقات
عمليات نزوح محدوده لبعض العائلات ولكن ما
ان هدات الامور او ان توقفت او ان كانت
الغارات اقتصر الرد على هذه المواقع حتى
عدت الامور الى وضعها الطبيعي حتى ان
وحدات الجيش اللب التي كانت منتشره ايضا
في البقعه التي استهدفتها هي ايضا انسحبت
منها والمواطنون
يذهبون اليها كزيارات تفقديه او كزيارات
على الذي جرى وايضا تكشفت بطبيعه الحال
عمليات الاضرار التي يطالب المواطنون
الحكومه اين يكون هنالك وفود منها وتحديدا
من هيئه الاغاثه للكشف عليها ولكن دعني
اذا كان معي من الوقت وتحديدا على ان الذي
يجري في الداخل الاسرائيلي من عند جهه
الزميل زياد وايضا يظهر الى ان هنالك شد
حبال على المستوى الاعلامي بالمواقف حتى
الامور لا تنفجر منذ بعض الوقت وايضا خلال
24 ساعه لم يسجل لدينا اي تصريح لمسؤول
سياسي مهم في حزب الله لميذ بعض الوقت غرد
النائب الامين العام لحزب الله شيخ نعيم
قاسم بالقول انه لن تنفع عن ثريات القاده
الصهاينه في التهديد والتهويل بالذي ربطا
بالذي يجري في الداخل وقال ان المجاهدون
الفلسطينيون في الميدان وكل محور المقاومه
في يقظه وهذا الذي كنت اريد ان اقول اليه
بعمليات الربط على الجبهات ما بين الضفه
والقدس الى الاغوار الى جنوب لبنان ممتاز
اعود لك مره اخرى زياد يعني هناك اجتماعات
مرتقبه ربما اليوم رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي نتنياهو مع قيادات عسكريه
امنيه ايضا كذلك ربما ايضا اجتماعات
لرئاسه الاركان ووزير الدفاع ما المتوقع
منها هل هناك رد على الاقل متوقع على ما
حدث في الاغوار هذه العمليه التي قتل فيها
او قتلت فيها ثلاث مستوطنات
ما المتوقع زيد
هذه الاشكاليه بالنسبه لاسرائيل رد يعني
ضد من عمليا هذه عمليه فرديه ليس هناك
لاسرائيل ان ترد على
ان تفعل اي شيء تقريبا نعم بالضبط ما عدا
ان تحاول ان تصل الى منفذي العمليه وهذا
هو الجهد الاساسي حقيقه على الارض وزير
الدفاع انها المشاورات الامنيه وجه الجيش
الاسرائيلي الى ضروره حمايه المستوطنات
الاسرائيليه والمحاور التي يتحرك عليها
المستوطنون في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله
بطبيعه الحال اسرائيل تقر بان العمليات
الفرديه او الذئاب الفرديه كما اسميتها هي
اشكاليه لانه عمليا لا تملك اسرائيل في
العاده اي معلومات استخباراتيه مسبقه
تمكنها من الاستعداد فقط عندما تحدث هذه
العمليه يمكن التعامل معها والمشكله في
هذه العمليات بانها تتكرر طوال الوقت مع
الحديث طبعا عن الجبه المشتعله بسبب ما
حدث في المسجد الاقصى وما الى ذلك
عمليا هناك ايضا بدات نوع من الازمنه داخل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه مرتين المره الاولى
لان هناك غضبا في اليمين الاسرائيلي بسبب
ترهل الرد الاسرائيلي لعمليا يعني الذي
اعتبروه هزيلا ان كان على الاراضي
اللبنانيه او على قطاع غزه وفق ما قال
نواب في حزب مثلا
قبل بعض الوقت صرح ايضا وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي المتطرف سبوترج قال انا احاول
ان ابقى مخلصا لهذه الحكومه لكن باتت لديه
صعوبه في الاشاره طبعا الى عمليه الاغوار
ومقتل مستوطنات هذا الامر يشكل ضاضا على
اليمين الصهيوني الايديولوجي في اسرائيل
محمود اخيرا تحدثت عن الاضرار حصر الاضرار
وان المطالبات من بعض المواطنين بتعويضهم
من قبل الحكومه
اللبنانيه كيف يمكن الحديث عن هذه
الخسائر الماديه التي وقعت حجم ايضا كذلك
هذه الاضرار بالنسبه للموجودين في جنوب
لبنان والذين اطالهم هذا القصف الاسرائيلي
نعم ثلاثه اماكن مستهدفه هي كانت في
الاماكن المفتوحه الجسر الى منطقه مزرعه
الليمون الى ايضا مزرعه اخرى فيها للمواشي
ما عدا ذلك كان هناك بعض الابنيه في داخل
المخيم الذي وراء المباشره عند الساحل
وهنا ايضا نعود ليس بعمليه الاضرار الى
المشكله الاساسيه التي هي في الداخل
الاسرائيلي والتي ايضا تنفذ على داخل
اللبناني هي الافتقاد الى مركزيه البنوك
للاهداف بمعنى تبسيطي انه ليس هنالك من
اهداف عسكريه لحركه حماس كتخزين ومواقع
وهلم حتى تستهدفها هذه الغارات او يمكن ان
تستهدفها الا اذا كان في بعض الشقق لبعض
الشخصيات الامنيه او العسكريه والتي هي
بطبيعه الحال في غايه السريه لذلك هذه
الغارات كانت على تلك الاماكن المفتوحه
والاضرار ايضا جاءت هي محدوده ان كان ببعض
الشقق وبالعصف على الشعاع ما يقارب 500
الى 700 متر في كل شغاره من تشقق لابنيه
او تحطم للزجاج او ايضا لعمليات الخزانات
المياه التي تكون على سطوح البيانات
البيانات ما عدا ذلك يعني بالتبسيط الهدوء
الى ان الثمن الطلعات الاسرائيليه
والغارات والطائرات والذخيره لم يكن على
قدر الاهداف التي استهدفت بالمفهوم
العسكري على الارض اشكركما جزيل الشكر من
جنوب لبنان محمود شكر مراسل العربيه من
الحدود الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه مدير مكتب
العربيه زياد حلبي شكرا جزيلا لكم
والى الملف اليمني حيث نقلت رويترز عن
مصادر قولها انه وقت سعودية عماني يعتزم
التوجه لصنعاء الاسبوع المقبل لبحث هدنه
دائمه بين اليمنيين اوضحت المصادر ان
الاطراف اليمنيه قد تعلن عن اتفاق هدنه
قبل العيد في العشرين من ابريل اذا نجحت
المحادثات
وكانت صحيفه الشرق الاوسط قد نقلت عن
مصادر يمنيه بان المسوده خطه السلام
الشامله للازمه في اليمن في اخر مراحل
اعدادها برعايه امميه حيث تتضمن اربعه
مراحل اولها وقف شامل لاطلاق النار في
البلاد وفتح جميع المنافذ البريه والجويه
والبحريه ثم تشكيل لجان لدمج البنك
المركزي وتبادل الاسرى والمعتقلين تليها
مرحله التفاوض المباشر لتاسيس شكل الدوله
واخيرا المرحله الانتقاليه
وينضم الينا من لندن الكاتب الصحفي في
جريده الشرق الاوسط بدر القحطاني سيد بدر
مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
من الرياض وفق يعني ما جاءت به الشرق
الاوسط حول مسوده خطه السلام الشامله
نسال هنا يعني وفق ما جاء في هذه
المسوده كما سرب ايضا للشرق الاوسط هل من
ضمانات الالتزام الحوثيين بتنفيذ بنود هذه
هذا الاتفاق او هذه
المسوده وكيف تقراها قبل ذلك
الوساطه التي اجرتها السعوديه
والدبلوماسيه السعوديه بمشاركه عمانيه
وكانت منذ وقت طويل جدا
[موسيقى]
يعني من وجهه نظر شخصيه في اطارها الشامل
بدي هي وقف النار طبيعي جدا للدخول في اي
عمليه سلام موضوع الهدنه الاماميه كانت
السابق تتحدث الامم المتحده عن سته اشهر
اعتقد تفاصيل التقنيه والتمديد الى عام
كامل مع التزام جميع الاطراف سيعود بالنفع
على الجميع بطبيعه الحال
التفاصيل الى الى اللحظه ليست حاسمه وليست
نهايه ولكن من الله جدا
الى مده قليله جدا في اليمن
فكان كثير من الفرقاء يحاول ان يصل الى
المطامع السياسيه واطماحه
واهدافها بالعنف اليوم نحن نرى الفرقاء
اليمنيين
بمختلف
مشاريعهم وتوجهاتهم الجميع يحاول ان يحقق
من كاسب سياسيا عن طريق الحل والسلمي
والحوار وهذا سناتي على بعض هذه القضايا
لكن دعني اسال عن الفترات الزمنيه ثلاثه
اشهر ثم سته اشهر اربعه مراحل هل هذه
المدد الزمنيه فترات كافيه لحلحله هذه
الازمه والوصول اخيرا الى مرحله الى حل
طبعا
يعني سياسي وبعد ذلك ايضا انتقال الى
المرحله الانتقاليه اخيرا كما جاء في هذه
المسود الفترات الزمنيه وهذه المده كافيه
دعني اجيب اولا على السؤال الاول موضوع
الضمانات من المستحيل وجود ايضا حتى لو
الاعلنت ايران بنفسها انها تضمن البعودين
هذا لا يعطي ضمانه لكن من المهم جدا اعطاء
المزيد من الفرص للحلول السلبيه هذه نقطه
النقطه الاخرى مساله تقسيم المراحل المهمه
جدا لان
مع الخبره والسنين الحرب
مساله الهدن المفتوحه والملفات غير
المزمنه دائما ما تنول بالفشل وتنور ايضا
بتفسيرات بين مختلف الاطراف لهذا السبب
بغض النظر عن كم هي المده على لكل مرحله
هي سنتين ام سته اشهر او سنتين نفسها تقسم
على سته اشهر بغض النظر عن هذه التفاصيل
التي
لود هذه
المراحل تبني الثقه وتعيدها لان الكثير من
الاطراف لمده ثمانيه وتسعه اعوام وهم على
خلاف من غير من غير الوارد ان يتفقوا وان
يكونوا على وفاق الامر الاخر امر احيانا
السياسيين عندما تكون على الامور لا نراها
تنعكس مباشره على الارض فبالتالي هذا يعطي
مساحه ومسافه للقرارات
والالتزامات بان يتم ترجمتها من اعلى
الهرم الى القيادات
يعني ربما هذه المسوده لم تتحدث عن الوضع
العسكري الحالي او كيف سيكون الوضع
العسكري ايضا حتى في الايام المقبله وهي
احد احدى ربما الاشكاليات خلال الايام
الماضيه بالتالي كيف يمكن التعامل مع
الاوضاع العسكريه الترتيبات ايضا كيف ستتم
هل
ستسبق او ستكون هناك شروط مسبقه لاي دخول
في الموضوع العسكري او اي حلول ايضا اما
انه سيكون من ضمن يعني ما سيتمخض عن هذه
المحادثات ربما او
الاجتماع بين الفرقاء والجلوس على طاوله
حوار سياسي
برايك سيد بدر
ايضا مطروحه للدراسه وهي عباره عن لجنه
عسكريه وامنيه تدرس مساله الناحيه
العسكريه ولكن لا ننسى ان وقف اطلاق النار
هو اهم عمليه عسكريه اصلا ستمهد لكل
الاصلاحات السياسيه او الاقتصاديه او
الانسانيه او حتى التنمويه المقبله سواء
داخل المرحله الانتقاليه او حتى قبلها فمن
دون وقف لاطلاق النار كل الاطراف لن تعني
الاصلاحات السياسيه او المراحل الانتقاليه
اي شيء ستكون مجرد تاجير للصرافه مستقبل
قاتل بينما لو بدات بوقف النار والتزام به
فستكون هذه علامه المستقبل في اي سياق
وضعت قضيه الجنوب في هذه المسوده برايك
سيد بدر
المجلس الانتقال الجنوبي ونشامى حتى في
صباح اليوم
ان هناك اجتماع عقد بين الاعضاء الج
نوبيه قياده الرئاسي وهم عيدروس الزبيدي
وعبد الرحمن ابو زرعه
وعبد الله العليمي باوزير
ولواء فرج المحصن وهؤلاء تم تشكيل لجنه من
قبل مجلس القياده الر
ئاسي بعضويه الاربعه وعقد الاجتماع لكي
يضعوا كل الاطر المناسبه لان تكون قضيه
الجنوب قضيه حاضره واحده من الملفات
الرئيسيه ضمن الملفات التي يتم نقاشها في
الحل اليمني وهذا اعتقد انه تقدم لافت لان
نعرف ان الفرقاء الجنوبيين انفسهم لديهم
وجهه نظر مخت وعندما يجلسون على الطاوله
ويتحدثون بالسلم وبالسياسه نرى ان هذا
تقدم كبير في الازمان اشكرك جزيل الشكر من
لندن الكاتب الصحفي في جريده الشرق الاوسط
بدر القحطاني شكرا
يعد لقاء وزيري الخارجيه السعوديه
والايراني في الصين واحدا من محطات من
محطات وتحولات عديده شهدتها العلاقه بين
البلدين خلال العقود الماضي الزميله
العنود العبدلي تعرفون على ابرز تلك
التحولات نتابع
طوال عقود ماضيه لم تكن العلاقات السعوديه
الايرانيه في افضل احوالها الا انها تعود
الان لمسار اكثر هدوءا العام
1943 شهد اول قطع العلاقات بين البلدين ثم
العام
1987 بعد الحادثه التي عرفت انذاك باحداث
مكه واخر الازمات مشاهدينا اقتحام السفاره
السعوديه في عام 2016 الذين تجاع عنه
قطعون ثالث للعلاقات اليوم رغم كل هذه
الازمات والخلافات تبدا الرياض رحله
علاقات جديده مع طهران برعايه صينيه بعد
وساطه العاشر من مارس الماضي التي نصت على
استئناف العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بينهما
واعاده فتح السفارتين والممثليات
الدبلوماسيه في غضون شهرين من تاريخ توقيع
الاتفاق كما تضمنت اعاده تفعيل اتفاقيه
التعاون الامني من السعوديه وايران
الموقعه في ابريل 2001
العامه للتعاون في مجال الاقتصاد والتجاره
والاستثمار والتقنيه والعلوم والثقافه
والرياضه والشباب الموقعه في مايو
الوصول الى هذا الى هذا الاتفاق مشاهدينا
مره بالعديد من جلسات الحوار والنقاش التي
استضافتها العراق وسلطنه عمان خلال عامين
الماضيين الا ان الاعلان عن الاتفاق جاء
من بكين اللاعب الدبلوماسي الاحدث والاكبر
في الساحه الدوليه دور صيني مفاجئ كما
وصفه الكثير من المراقبين الا ان غرابته
تتلاشى في ظل العلاقات الجيده لتربط
بالرياضي وطهران اتصالات جرت ولقاءات
مستمره في خطوات جاده لاعاده العلاقات بين
البلدين نحو مسارها الطبيعي
اعلن الصندوق السعودي للتنميه عن توقيع
اتفاقيه تمويل مع وزاره الطاقه
الباكستانيه لتمويل سد مهما للطاقه
الكهرومائيه وذلك عن طريق تقديم قرض تنموي
ميسر من السعوديه لباكستان حيث جاءت تمويل
السعودي بقيمه تتجاوز 240 مليون دولار
امريكي بهدف دعم امدادات الطاقه والمياه
المخصصه للزراعه والاستهلاك اليومي
والحمايه من مخاطر الفيضانات
هذا مشروعي الى تعزيز استخدام الطاقه
المتجدده للاسهام في توفير الطاقه
المستدامه ودعم مسيره التنميه في جمهوريه
باكستان الاسلاميه الشقيقه من خلال الطاقه
على الانتاجيه الكهربائيه التي تولد 800
ميجا وات الى بالاضافه الى تخزين واحد
فاصله سته مليون متر مكعب من المياه
لتوفير مصادر مائيه للاستخدام البشري
والزراعي
اليوم يوم مهم حيث وقعنا اتفاق سد مهما
متعدد الاستخدامات فهو مفيد للاقتصاد
الباكستاني حيث سيوفر 800 ميجا واط من
الكهرباء للشبكه الوطنيه كما سيوفر
امدادات مياه لنحو 60 الف هكتار للاراضي
الزراعيه
الرابعه مستمره وفي بعد قليل
هيئه النقل السعودي تدشر اول حافله
كهربائيه للنقل الترددي بين مطار المدينه
والحرم النبوي
حياكم الله من جديد كشفت هيئه الاحصائي
السعوديه عن احصاءات النقل الجوي في
البلاد لعام 2022 حيث بلغ عدد الركابه
الذين تم نقلهم عبر الرحلات الدوليه
والداخليه 88 مليون راكب ارتفاع 82% عن
العام الذي سبقت كما ارتفع عدد الرحلات
الجويه لنفس العام بكافه المطارات في
المملكه بنسبه
41% مقارنه بعام 2021 فيما بلغ عدد الدول
التي ارتبطت بها المطارات السعوديه 56
دوله بزياده عشر دول عن عام 2021
ضم الينا في الاستوديو الخبير في قطاع
الطيران المهندس الطيار طارق العيد مهندس
طارق حياك الله اهلا وسهلا فيك خليني احكي
اولا عن هذه الارقام وبتحديدا نسبه النمو
هل كانت وفق التوقعات برايك
اولا كل عام وانتم بخير وصحه الاعمال
والحمد لله ما شاء الله مبروك علينا هذه
الارقام ارقام صراحه جدا جميله بالبدايه
قبل ما نخوض تفاصيل تقرير الهيئه العامه
للاحصاء في
2022 حركه النقل الجويه في مطارات
السعوديه
احب يعني اذكر في سنتين معياريه للمقارنات
في قطاع الطيران في اي مكان في العالم
السنه المعياريه الاولى 2019 كونها هي
السنه اللي كان فيها حقيقه اداء متميزه
قطاع الطيران في العالم اجمع قبل الجائحه
والسنه المعياريه الثانيه 2022
ضروري تكون في تفصيل 22 و 19 في الركاب
والشحن كل كل الاوجاع
بالنسبه
لحركه النقل الجوي في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه مقارنه 2022 بالعام السابق 2021
اصبح ان الارتفاع تقريبا 66% بعدد مسافرين
وصلنا 88 مليون مسافر مقارنه بخمسين مليون
مسافر في 2021 ارتفاع 66% للاسباب اسباب
عوامل مساعده كثيره بعده جهات حكوميه
تاشيرات السياحيه الحج والعمره التعافي
القوه الناعمه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
احتضان المؤتمرات تشجيع السياحه الداخليه
واسباب متعدده النقطه الاهم اللي نستشهد
فيها من الجانب هذا انه اول ضربت الجائحه
العالم 2020 في الربع الاول ظهرت اصوات من
الاتحاد الدولي النقل الجوي وعده منظمات
تعني قطاع الطيران
مطر دبي في الخليج سجل تراجع عن 2019 2022
مقارنه 2019 سجل تراجع بمقدار 24% اذا
نظرنا محليا مطار الملك خالد الدولي للتو
اعلن ارقام الربع الاول ل 2023
سجل ارتفاع 11% مقارنه للسنه المعيريه في
2019 انت متعافيت لا انت انت تجاوزت الملك
عبد العزيز ايضا مطار الدولي ما اعلن
كرقام الربع الاول 2023 لكن اذا تكلمنا عن
2022 سنه بسنه مقارنه
مفرمت خالد الدولي سجل ارقام اعلى من 2019
ايضا كساره بسنه سجل قرابه 28 مليون مسافر
تقريبا 27 مليون وسافروا وكسر بالارقام
اذا نظرنا الارقام هذه والتعافي وتيره
التعافي السريعه هذه عندنا تقريبا تقريبا
اثنين وثمانين الف مسافر يوميا يعبر مطار
الملك خالد الدولي مقارنه ب75 الف مسافر
متوسط في 2019
وتيره التعافي سريعه جدا ممتاز وهذا
يدفعنا نسال عنها حجم هذا النمو اللي
تصرفه بانه وتيرته متسارعه وين ممكن نضعها
بالنسبه
للمستهدفات المملكه العربيه السعوديه في
رؤيه
2030 يعني احنا عندنا عدد مستهدف للركاب
للزوار وغيرها الارقام وين ممكن هل يمكن
ان نصل لهذه المستذف قبل عشرين ثلاثين
ممتاز عشرين ثلاثين من ناحيه مستهدفات
ارقام تفضل تخوي نايف يستهدف مئه وجهه حول
العالم من الرياض تنطلق من الرياض يربطها
بمئه وجهه على على 2030
في 2019 الرياض ترتبط ب75 وجهه عالميه في
الربع الاول 2023 الرياض ترتبط ب 82 وجهه
عالميه ارتفاع اذا قارنا سنه معياري 2019
انت قريب تقريبا باقي لك يعني اقل من 15
الى 16% حتى توصل الارقام 2020 20 30 من
ناحيه عدد وجهات تربطك في العالم هذا اذا
نظرنا للوضع الحالي الان
خلينا نظهر الوضع المتفاعل للتو يعني
سمعنا بتدشين مبارك بمطار الملك سلمان
الدولي شركه طيران الرياض
لحد الان يعني ما بعد يعني
اول طائره 33 طائره 39 طائره مؤكده شراء
عندك 33 طائره احقيه شراء في من بوينج
يعني انت تتكلم عن تقريبا قرابه 78 طائره
تقريبا او 68 طائره في شركه طيران الرياض
راح تكون تنطلق من الرياض هذه ارقام شبه
مؤكده الان الطلبيه الشراء
ارقام متفائله جدا واعتقد انه وتيره النمو
تزود عن 11% يعني في الرياض
خالد الدوري كان سبعه ونص مليون مسافر
مقارنه بسته ونصف مليون مسافر في 2015
اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل المعلومات
التفاصيل الارقام ايضا
كان معي هنا في قطاع الطيران المهندس
الطيار طارق العيد شكرا
للمره الاولى في المدينه المنوره دشنت
هيئه نقل العام اول حافله كهربائيه صديقه
للبيئه تعمل على نقل المصلين من والى
المسجد النبوي طوال شهر رمضان تقدم الخدمه
اكثر من 16 رحله يوميا على مدار 18 ساعات
تفاصيل برفقه الزميل سلطان السلمى
[موسيقى]
بنت والى المسجد النبوي تنقل هذه الحافله
الكهربائيه الصديقه للبيئه المصلين طوال
شهر رمضان كخدمه جديده تدخل ضمن اسطول
حافلات المدينه الذي قام بنقل اكثر من 300
الف راكب
[موسيقى]
تمتاز الحافله الكهربائيه بالكفاءه
التشغيليه العاليه التي تمكنها من السير
لمسافه
250 كيلومترا في الشحنه الواحده عبر مسار
مخصص يربط مطار الامير محمد بن عبد العزيز
بالمسجد النبوي الشريف تردديا بمسافه
اجماليه تصل الى 38 كيلومترا ومن المقرر
ان تقدم هذه الخدمه الجديده اكثر من 16
رحله يوميا في مميزات كثيره عندك الشاحن
المتنقل في الحافله الكهربائيه تشحن جوالك
لطفا مثلا قطع جوالك تشحنه ثاني شيء
التحرك هدوء ما في ارتجاج سهله جدا توصلك
لما تبغى بصراحه اول تجربه بالنسبه
للحافلات الكهربائيه وكثير انبسطت فيها
لان صديقه للبيئه وكمان كل الخدمات كانت
كويسه الحافله الكهربائيه تاتي ضمن
مستهدفات الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للنقل
والخدمات اللوجستيه الهادفه الى تبني
الوسائل والتقنيات الحديثه في انشطه
وخدمات النقل والعمل على خفض الانبعاثات
الكربونيه بنسبه
25% ورفعه حصه استخدام وسائل النقل العام
في السعوديه الى 15 بالمئه بحلول
230 من المدينه المنوره سلطان السلمي
العربيه
ونبقى في المدينه حيث تشكل جاده قبل مزارا
يوميا يشهد اقبالا وحركه تنقل كبيره خلال
شهر رمضان اقصدها هذه المدينه وزوارها
لاداء الصلوات بالمسجد النبوي ومسجدي
قباوى تربط الجاده المسجدين بمساره للمشاه
يمتد على طول ثلاثه كيلو مترات
من المدينه المنوره ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه سلطان السلمي سلطان مساء الخير
مرحبا بكم معي في نشاط الرابعه من الرياض
انت موجود في هذه الجاده التي تربط بين
المسجد النبوي ومسجد قبح حدثني عن هذا
المشروع عبر الارقام التفاصيل حوله ايضا
اهلا بكافه مشاهدين نشره الرابعه بالفعل
نقف الان في منتصف المسار الذي خصص
ولعمليه الربط بين مسجد قباء والمسجد
النبوي كان يسمى هذه الجاده بضرب السنه
نتحدث عن مسار بطول يصل الى ثلاثه كيلو
مترات يربطه بين مسجد قباء والمسجد النبوي
يتكون هذا المشروع بعدد كبير من المحاله
التجاريه والمقاهي والمطاعم التي تقدم
الاكلات والثقافه المدينيه هنا في هذا
المسار الذي يشهد اقبال كبير وكثيف من قبل
المصلين وزوار المسجد النبوي وكذلك اهالي
المدينه تتحدثن بارقام هنالك اكثر من 20
الف زائر يوميا يزور هذه الجاده انتقالا
من مسجد قباء الى المسجد النبوي او العكس
نتحدث انه تم تهيئه هذا المسار من خلال
العمليات الانسنه والتسجيل وكذلك تخصيص
عربات جولف الكار لكبار السن وذوي
الاحتياجات الذين لا يستطيعون السير في
هذا المسار الذي يصل طوله الى ثلاثه كيلو
مت نتحدث عن خدمات وبنيه تحتيه داخل هذا
المسار تم تجهيزه وتهيتها من قبل الجهات
الحكوميه العامله هنا في المدينه المنوره
اليوم هذا المسار ياخذ الزائر او المصلي
القادم الى المسجد النبوي في جوله تعريفيه
بكافه المحال وكذلك الاكلات المدينيه
وخصوصا في شهر رمضان نشاهد هنالك الشريك
والدك المدينيه وغيرهم الماكولات لذلك
يحرص المصلين والزوار خصوصا زوار مصلين
الخارج القادمين الى المدينه المنوره
يحرسون على زياره هذا المكان الاستمتاع
وتناول وجبات الافطار او حتى وجبات السحور
كذلك اليوم حتى العائله المدنيه تستطيع
الاستمتاع بشكل كبير في هذا المسار برفقه
عائلاتهم واطفالهم لما هنالك من محل للسوق
او محل للاسره المنتجه وكذلك براندات
عالميه او حتى براندات محليه هيك عن دورات
المياه والمطاعم والمقاهي وكل ما يتعلق
بالاسره او الزائر سوف يجدوا ويستمتع به
في هذا المسار التي تم تزيينه بالاشجار
وكذلك الانوار التي النسب مع الحله
الرمضانيه كذلك نتحدث عن وجود كافه
الخيارات او الجلسات المناسبه للعوائل
التي تستطيع من خلالها الاستمتاع بشكل
كبير مساء البارحه كنا متواجدون ليلا هنا
هنالك اعداد كبيره وضخمه يشهدها هذه
المنطقه من خصوصا الاطفال والعائلات هنالك
الالعاب يعتبر يعني يا نايف كانه متنزه
ترفيهي ومسار للمهتمين والراغبين بالتنقل
بين مسجد قباء والمسجد النبوي كما نشاهد
الزوار الخليجيين وغيرهم يستهدفوهن هذا
المكان لما به من كافه الخدمات
والمستلزمات التي يرغبون بالحصول عليها
هنا في هذه المنطقه اشكرك جزيل الشكر على
كل هذه المعلومات التفاصيل الصوره التي
نقلتها لنا من المدينه المنوره مراسل
العربيه السلطان السلامي شكرا يا سلطان
خطته لتفويج الملايين من المعتمرين
والمصلين في شهر رمضان وضعتها اداره
الحشود داخل الحرم المكي ضمن سلسله من
الخطه والخدمات لاداء المناسك الدينيه
بيسر وسهوله كما خصصت اداره الحشود اكثر
من سته مداخل تسهيل الدخول المعتمرين
واداء العمره والوصول الى صحن المطاف في
الدور الارضي
من الحرم المكي مراسل العربيه اسامه
القاسم اسامه مرحبا بك معي كيف هي الصوره
لديك المداخل ايضا الموده الى صحن المطاف
كيف تبدو العمليه والحركه فيها حتى الان
اهلا لجميع مشاهدي قناه العربيه الاجواء
اللطيفه اليوم في المسجد الحرام طبعا
نتحدث اليوم عن الحركه التنظيميه والتنظيم
الحشود المتواجده اليوم في المسجد الحرام
وصلنا اليوم الى حوالي 14 مليون زائر
ومعتمر منذ بدايه شهر رمضان المبارك
وبدايه الخطه التشغيليه الاولى التي اعلنت
عنها الرئاسه في نهايه العشر الاولى عن
نجاحها بالكامل وبدايه الخطه التشغيليه
الثانيه اترككم الان في صوره حول هذه
الجموع التي تدخل الان الى صحن المطاف من
باب الملك عبد العزيز طبعا هناك سته ابواب
متاحه للدخول الى صحن المطاف والادوار
العلويه ايضا هو باب الملك عبد العزيز
وباب الملك فهد وباب الفتح وباب العمره
وباب الزبير وباب السلام سته ابواب مخصصه
للدخول الى ساحات او عفوا المسجد الحرام
وصحن المطاف بشكل خاص طبعا نتحدث اليوم
ايضا عن الخط التنظيميه التي ترعاها رئاسه
شؤون الحرمين وايضا الجهات المسانده كان
الحج والعمره والجهات الاخرى التي ترعى
اليوم الخطه التنظيميه بشكل كبير وبشكل
محكم بشكل كبير جدا اليوم نحن نقف بجانب
باب الملك عبد العزيز الذي يشهد تواجد
الكثير من الزوار المعتمين الداخلين الى
صحن المطاف ونشهد هنا ايضا الزحام
الموجوده في الداخلين من جهه اجياد وايضا
باب اجياد الداخلين الى ساحات المسجد
الحرام ليؤدوهم الى الابواب الاخرى طبعا
اذا صار هناك ازدحام في باب من الابواب
يؤدونهم مباشره الى الابواب الاخرى لكي
يفتتوا هذه الزحام ويحاولوا احتواء هذه
الازدحامات الشديده طبعا تحدث اليوم ايضا
على ان هناك لوحات ارشاديه وتنبيهيه من
قبل رجال امن الحج والعمره تؤدي بمفاد
واحد الى ان صحن المطاف مثلا ممتلئ هذه
الساحه ممتلئه هذا المكان ممتلئ ثم ان
يوجهونهم بشكل مباشر الى الابواب الاخرى
والى الساحات الاخرى طبعا اثناء صلاه
التراويح يتم اغلاق الابواب مؤقتا حتى
يخرج المصلين
ثم من يعود مجددا فتح الابواب لدخولهم الى
صحن المطاف وفق حركه محكمه ومنظمه بشكل
كبير جدا اتحدث اليوم ايضا عن على ان هذه
الاعداد تزيد يوما بعد يوم وباحتمال بشكل
كبير جدا تزيد هذه الاعداد خلال ايام
القادمه حتى نشهد الخطه التشغيليه الثالثه
الاكبر التي تبدا في العشر الاواخر مع ذلك
ليس هنالك اي شيء يذكر من حالات مثلا الا
بعض الحالات البسيطه كحالات الاعياء
البسيطه على كبار السن او المرضى الحركه
تسير بشكل كبير جدا اليوم جمعه ويتوقع
بشكل كبير جدا ان تزيد الاعداد خلال هذه
الايام نشهد الان رغم اننا في تمام الساعه
الرابعه ونصف لنا هذه الاعداد الوفيره
ايضا قابله للزياده في الايام او في
الساعات القادمه بحول الله تعالى اليوم
الخطه التنظيميه والخطه التشغيليه تسير
وفق خطط ممنهجه من قبل شراكه كبيره مع
الجهات الموجوده اليوم في الحرم المكي ومن
مصدر مسؤول ايضا اعلن بان هناك خطه
تشغيليه اكبر ستكون هناك في العشر الاواخر
طبعا اتح دث اليوم نايف عن حركه كبيره جدا
وسلسه للزوار والمعتمرين الداخلين الى صحن
المطاف او حتى الادوار العلويه خرجنا قبل
قليل ببعد الصلاه من صحن المطاف الادوار
العلويه الثلاثه وصحن المطاف ممتلئين
بالكامل وتوقعات ايضا من تزداد هذه
الاعداد في الساعات القادمه نتابع معكم ان
شاء الله في نشراتنا القادمه شكرا جزيلا
لك من الحرم المكي مراسل العربيه اسامه
القاسم على كل هذه المعلومات التفاصيل
خلال 14 يوما فقط حققت منصه وجود الاسكاني
في السعوديه مستدفات حمله اكتتاب جود
الاسكان الخيري والمتمثل بجمع مليار ريال
حيث اعلنت المبادره انه سيتم توفير المسكن
لثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه الاسر الاشد احتياجا
هذا ومن المقرر ان تتواصل الحمله تستقبال
المساهمات في اول اكتتاب خيري بقطاع
الاسكان على مستوى العالم حتى نهايه مده
محدده بنهايه شهر رمضان
بجانبي كشف وزير الشؤون البلديه والقرويه
والاسكان ماجد الحقير للعربيه انا مساهمه
الافراد في اكتتاب جوده الاسكان تجاوزت
الثلاثين مليون ريال مبينا ان الاكتتاب لا
يزال مستمرا وسيحقق المزيد من الارقام
خلال الايام القادمه
الجيش الاسرائيلي يستدعي عشرات ضباط
الاحتياط ووزير الدفاع يوجهه بزياده تامين
المستوطنات
امكانيه اعلان هدنه بين اليمنيين قبل
العيد اذا نجحت محادثات تقودها الرياض
ومسقط
الصندوق السعودي للتنميه للتنميه يوقع
اتفاقيه لتمويل بناء سد في باكستان بنحو
ربع مليار دولار
ارتفاع عدد ركاب المطارات السعوديه باكثر
من 80% خلال عام 2022
هيئه النقل السعوديه تدشن اول حافله
كهربائيه للنقل الترددي بين مطار المدينه
والحرم النبوي
شكرا لكم على كرمي ولطف المتابعه دائما
العربيه لمزيد من الاخبار والمعلومات
نهايه الرابعه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات